Okay so next question I touched on there's a clinic in Tempia, Arizona that
tells 90% remissions. Dr. Hubert points out that following their protocols
patients who do not include sugar, that is they're doing more of a keto diet.
Have a 90% success and successful in going into revision while those who do each
sugar are at about 36%. Now I would say that that statistic has some merit that
you could pull those numbers completely but I think people do better the less glucose
they consume because no not every cancer is only going to feed off of glucose.
I do think that all cells would prefer to use glucose so cancer cells as
well they'll still use glucose so glycolysis is the normal preferred method of
production of ATP you know in all cells so if you could emit that that is good.
That means that I think you have to be switching up your diet at different intervals in order to keep a
cancer at bay so I have a thinking of a treatment protocol has not been working as well as I
would like and the blood reason is that I'm consistently cheating when it comes to sugar
yes I use low glycemic sugar such as lung fruit but while at first I go
off and completely I started having high carb meals and then for a time and chocolates
I tried to stay with dark chocolate almost every day or not a dairy ice cream bar on occasion
while I've dropped that now I know I'm wearing a muffin on occasion but mostly with high
sugar fruit or juice tied through sugar fruits which I thought was okay I hate to admit it but it creeps
out going to dinner with friends doesn't always happen yeah I know it's hard but I do think
that you know that that's you know you can get some should get around that somewhat by doing
it and fasting but still if you're cheating if you're especially if your cancer is
growing you have to get super super serious and strict on your diet but even
people that are on a really super strict ketogenic diet for a long time their cancer can find
another fuel source so you have to be willing to pivot pretty quick so if it starts feeding
mainly off glutamine after there's no glucose and you've had a revision for three to six months
and now it starts the cancer starts pivoting to feed off of amino acids then you have to be able
to pivot quickly and get out of the mindset that I can't eat any carbs so it's it's just a balancing act so
again I would say you know try if you feel like your cancer is growing try to get really super serious
about like a more ketogenic type diet for a period of time see what happens do testing and see what happens
and see if there is if that was a piece just like the I said with testing yourself with the right of
and see